alors qu'est-ce que c'était que d'être marié,
c'est difficile à coup sûr,
mais il y a quelque chose qui fait du bien
de partager votre vie avec quelqu'un
comment partagez-vous votre vie avec quelqu'un
bien nous avons grandi ensemble agréable à lire
Oliver écrivant l'auteur sa maîtrise et son
doctorat elle a lu tous  mot que j'ai jamais écrit nous
étions une grande influence l'un pour l'autre je
me retrouve toujours à avoir une conversation
avec elle dans mon esprit en fait de vieux
arguments me défendant contre
quelque chose qu'elle a dit sur moi ouais je sais
ce que tu veux dire la semaine dernière mes sentiments ont été
blessés par quelque chose que tu as dit  avant cela, je
ne sais pas ce que c'est que de perdre
quelque chose et je me connais en ce qui concerne la
survie
ça n'allait pas avec moi c'était une histoire que
je me racontais que j'étais en quelque sorte
inférieur je ne m'intéresse pas le passé n'est
qu'une histoire que nous nous racontons